[Music]
part two
battle tendency is a complete and total
roller coaster
that is 25 longer 50 percent more naked
and 100 weirder than phantom blood but
did i think it was any better
you see battle tendency which largely
focuses on the story of jonathan
joestar's grandson joseph
is the final part i'm vaguely familiar
with in the same vein as the prior part
my memory concerning the events of
battle tendency were foggy to say the
least
with really the only things i remembered
being the pillarman a minecart and my
personal favorite jojo so far
joseph joestar as he uses his indiana
jones hammond and sherlock holmes powers
to beat the living daylights out of
nazis and magical naked monster men
so you know just a typical day in the
office for a rocky
speaking of which once again i'll be
reading the manga for the purposes of
this review so as to get as close as
possible to the original author's vision
and so without further ado i'm totally
not mark and this is my review for the
ambitious hilarious and
ridiculous battle tendency
[Music]
my
fifty years after the events of phantom
lead the grandson of jonathan joestar
joseph now living in new york city usa
has to travel to mexico and europe to
overcome the forces of the pilot a new
more powerful force of evil that makes
the vampires from the previous part
looked like cockroaches by comparison
added to being the first four pillar
then in mexico through clever tactics
joseph soon realizes that he was trained
to hold his abilities with his new best
friend forever
caesar grandson of will antonio
stephanie together they hunt down an
individual called lisa lisa and undergo
some brutal training however before his
training is completed jojo is attacked
by a killer man going by the name of
acdc
who does fight being much stronger than
the pillar man from mexico is eventually
overcome by jojo's new abilities
forces lead the jojo gang to switzerland
where his companion dies tragically
leaving just he and lisa lisa to take on
the remaining forces of wine and cars
the two remaining pyramids oh the
humanity
so this video was a little harder to
make you know the way that phantom blood
was pretty simple in terms of its story
two boys grew up together one good one
bad and some were in there
the bad guy puts on a demon vampire
zombie mask to make himself an immortal
lord of the underworld while the good
guy does some breathing karate to stop
him you know like i said a simple story
well this one is a lot more complicated
you got the grandson of jonathan the
joseph joestar character living with his
grandma arena and good friends with
speedwagon who is also an oil tycoon
that goes to mexico to see a large naked
man in a stone pillar
but gets captured by the nazis who want
to do experiments on the naked pillar
man
and once joseph finds out about this he
gets angry and hops in a motorcycle
before fighting a cape in the middle of
the desert using only a cactus
and that's just half of the first volume
and there are
four volumes okay jokes aside i actually
loved this story and i think it's more
effective as an arc than phantom blood
in almost every conceivable
way and it does so by standing on the
shoulders of the various characters and
mechanics phantom bloods already
established and i realize this almost
immediately because
battle tendency starts fast and i say
fast not because the scenes go
by at any unreasonable pace but because
the contents of these scenes
are intensely compelling for me there
were some very easily recognizable
differences with how battle tendency
was told compared with phantom blood i
very much enjoyed phantom blood for what
it was but one thing i thought it could
have done more with was
scene diversity you'll notice in phantom
blood outside of a scene here and there
towards the beginning the entire plot
takes place
in one story thread whereas in battle
tendency
the first act very much tells multiple
stories before
converging in on one towards the second
act but helped tremendously with pacing
issues that often arise in that section
however while that difference is greatly
appreciated one aspect i think
almost everyone noticed that elevated
the story beyond all others
was joseph joestar joe is bae
even if you rewound the clock back to
when i first saw the anime all those
years ago
despite my initial time being bad joseph
joestar was always a bright spot in that
series
for me of the three jojo's i had been
introduced to during that time he was
head and shoulders better than all of
the others for me or at least i was more
receptive to him more than anyone else
whether or not that will stand true to
jotaro next week
is another question now that i'll be
tackling the manga instead of the anime
but for the time being little 195
centimeter tall
joey joestar is a tremendously engaging
character to me
similarly to how jonathan was introduced
in phantom blood joseph's introductory
scene offers up a lot of information
about who he is as a character
and i think this is something araki has
done phenomenally well in the past as
well as here
in his 2015 book manga in theory and
practice araki spends a considerable
amount of time
expanding upon and delving into his
process when it comes to writing a
particular character
creating spreadsheets of common
attributes like their height weight and
birthday
but also traits that might be a little
bit more obscure like
criminal records dreams fears
relationship histories and
whether or not they are are not
colorblind and there are tons of other
elements that go into making his
character spreadsheets and this aspect
of his craft in particular i think is
something he improved upon greatly
between parts of one and two personally
while i liked jonathan's introductory
scene where he intervenes with some
bullies his less
important scenes thereafter felt less
compelling and
somewhat disconnected from the initial
introduction we experienced or at least
that's how i felt and while pivotal
moments dotted throughout
shared the same characteristics as the
first i think jonathan stands in great
contrast to what araki managed to create
with
joseph joestar his grandson because i
adored part two's introductory chapter
concerning joseph joestar
not just because it establishes a clear
tone for the character that he adheres
to religiously throughout but also
because he fulfills another
principle he preaches in his book that i
love the four pillars
of manga structure in his book he
describes these four fundamental pillars
as being
characters story setting and themes
and it's his implementation of these
four fundamentals that made this story
so compelling for me to read through he
says when creating a manga it is
incredibly important not to simply draw
on a whim but to be conscious of the
four fundamental elements as you draw
am i making good characters is my story
acceptable am i drawing a coherent
setting are my themes consistent and
steady and with that quote in mind
you'll notice that in joseph joestar's
introductory scene it takes care of all
of these qualities
while also helping us form a clear
understanding of who joe is
as a character joseph joestar unlike
phantom blood which begins with an
expository scene alongside the villain's
circumstances
this part launches off the heels of
joseph joestar's introductory chapter
the vast majority of this chapter is
dedicated to him and with great reason
as we soon will find out
right off the bat it's clear that the
story is taking place in a time period
far removed from late 19th century
england
old-fashioned cars zooming past statue
of liberty piercing the sky
and a coca-cola vendor on the streets
selling drinks from his stall
even the clothes people are wearing all
of this helps set the scene for the
adventure that this story enjoys
faced with the situation of being mugged
he notices the boy who did the mugging
being taken advantage of and bullied by
the cops that catch him soon after the
act instead of taking the mugging
personally joseph can recognize when
someone is in trouble
and vouches for the kid before getting
ticked off by the policemen and
introducing us to his level of hammond
competency
and with this brief scene we learn
everything we need to know about joseph
he's virtuous
and kind but also quick to temper but
perhaps the defining characteristic
joseph joestar demonstrates and sets him
apart from most of the others
is that of his intellect coming up with
an excuse for the young kid on the fly
is just a first taste of what joseph is
capable of doing once he puts his mind
to something as we will soon see in
almost every single fight scene that
takes place after this
and what i just said there is why for me
joseph is a terrific main character he
drives the plot has a terrific aura of
charisma but more than that he's a
consistent personality by the end of
this story i'd spend so much time with
joseph that i honestly felt like i knew
him which while i'm not trying to knock
jonathan is certainly not what i can say
about him personally and this
familiarity that i'm feeling as a reader
can be leveraged by the author too but
more on that in a little while secondary
characters
if there was one thing i thought jojo's
bizarre adventure lacked in part one it
was interesting or compelling secondary
characters the young friends jonathan
had his father the police and even
zeppelin to a large extent
lacked specific elements that prevented
them from being
compelling within the story though i
will say zeppeli is easily the most
well-realized side character
in part one but even in saying that he
isn't around for very long and when he
does pass on
it didn't really affect me in any strong
or appreciable way
i mean if one of your three strongest
supporting characters after
speedwagon and zeppeli is a dog with no
speaking lines
it makes you wonder if something might
be a miss here with that said however
secondary characters in battle tendency
play a significantly larger role with
the connection i felt to those
characters
feeling far more potent than the story
that came before it
but something i think is worth noting as
i mentioned towards the beginning of
this video battle tendency is fantastic
but
it is helped tremendously by leg work
phantom blood has done to establish
characters like straits
speedwagon and the zeppeli family line
as all of these characters are either
directly present in the story to elevate
the existing main character joseph or
their effects are present to affect
their lineage and i think it's important
to mention the side characters here
because the side characters in jojo's
bizarre adventure actually carry
most of the emotional weight from story
to story or at least
early on as far as i'm aware given my
limited exposure to the series
each new part boasts a new main
character and so
when that new guy shows up and is in the
process of winning us the audience over
we can still feel a connection to this
new material despite the old main
character having taken a backseat
because we still have a connection to
the familiar
faces we see on the sidelines i was
delighted to see
speedwagon and even straights in this
story and so in addition to erasing the
need for expository dialogue dumps
explaining who all these characters are
we can instead focus on the plot which
has made all the more streamlined
thanks to these individuals and by the
way the pacing in this part is
amazing at no point was i even remotely
bored there's always something to be
looking forward to or immediately
happening
straits whom we met in the very first
part for example is still kicking around
with speedwagon it's awesome to see from
in your faces and well
okay sort of it's been 50 years and
speedwagon looks much older however
straits only looks
marginally different thanks to the
hammond he's mastered to help him retain
some of his youth
and despite him being a character that
fought on the side of good
prior this character in straits is used
as the first minor antagonistic force in
the story and one for joseph to really
demonstrate where his strengths lie
and where his weaknesses are having gone
to mexico with speedwagon to investigate
some ruins straits ends up taking out
everyone including speedwagons seizing
the opportunity to wear the mask
and transform into a vampire returning
to new york where jojo is to confront
him this is the first main fight of the
story and one that pits our hero against
one of the main monsters from the last
part and this all takes place in the
first few chapters the pacing in this
story is honestly nuts with the fight
that ensues being even better
the fight scenes there are two sections
of fight scenes in this story or
at least two that i recognize the
pre-training arc fights and the
post-training arc fights
and both are great for different reasons
so let's take a look at the pre-training
arc stuff first
starting with the first major battle
joseph has in the series with the newly
young and vampiric
straits straight versus joseph joestar i
won't harp on about it for too long but
this is probably the most perfect a
first fight could be for a series like
jojo's bizarre adventure but more
specifically for battle tendency
similarly to the encounter with the
policemen we get with joseph in the
first chapter
this fight reinforces everything we've
learned to be true and consistent with
the character
of joseph in far more obvious ways one
aspect i didn't much care for beyond a
few interesting set pieces in phantom
blood
was the nature of its action while i
didn't feel it was bad i certainly
didn't feel like it had any significant
connection to the character of jonathan
but if there's one thing i can't fault
battle tendency for it's failing to be
memorable
joseph pulling a tummy gun out of thin
air throwing a grenade at him
only for straights to realize that the
grenade that he threw back at jojo
was attached to many other grenades on
his back all certainly elevate the level
of absurdity this story
bathes luxuriously in there's an almost
slapstick comedic quality that
accompanies this section along with the
intrigue that's obviously there as we
see joseph learn more and more about the
world he's entering into in this fight
it becomes apparent that what sets
joseph apart isn't his use of hammond
his
physical prowess or his personality even
instead it's his
intellect his ability to deconstruct
problems on the fly and come up with
more and more abstract solutions
to help him achieve victory in
ludicrously absurd ways
santana vs joseph joster i think of all
the action sequences in this first half
this one was probably my favorite there
was a fantastic element of mystery to it
the setting being that of a secret
military world war ii bunker conducting
experiments on the other worldly being
as a time and time again demonstrates
that it's far behind the understanding
of anything they have anticipated with
the creature known as santana
demonstrating to us
what exactly it was capable of when it
took out the vampire enemy that gave our
heroes so much trouble to deal with back
in phantom blood and it does so with
ease
elevating the scene further is a german
soldier higher up from the late 1930s
whose allegiance i am
specifically trying to avoid saying
let's die get struck down by the
demonetization gods of youtube his name
is strawheim and he
is likable i think well at least not at
first
after capturing speedwagon who's alive
by the way and after dealing with the
disaster this experiment turned out to
be
joseph arrives in the nick of time to
save the day and well
okay sort of he's there to save
speedwagon and really has no qualms with
santana initially but eventually things
elevate to a considerable degree and
despite the sinister elements that make
up this fight
it's actually really exciting and not
dark at all in fact it's kind of
light-hearted
pawn definitely intended with that one
in essence this fight acts as exposition
done right we learn a great deal about
who the pillar men are
what they can do and what's their
weakness sunlight and in addition to
jojo utilizing his intellect in creative
ways once again to gain the upper hand
strawheim makes a tenacious play that
allows the sunlight to pour onto the
weakened santana
one down three to go hello man versus
caesar and joseph jokestop
it's during the lead-up to this section
that the main groundwork set up for the
supporting cast is beginning to take
shape
joseph and speedwagon travel to rome to
meet a descendant of zeppeli
and his name
[Music]
the relationship jojo establishes with
caesar is the closest thing this arc
gets to compelling emotional
and memorable character writing and
that's not necessarily a bad thing i
adore jojo and caesar's blossoming
bromance as they overcome the various
challenges that sprout up before them
caesar zeppeli has a clearly defined
character
which is enjoyable and early on acts as
a terrific foil for jojo to bounce off
of
he's tremendously adept with hammond
mastery and so for the short term
immediately after meeting
represents a goal for jojo to reach for
and something for us the audience to
latch onto for jojo
soon after the fights that take place
with the pillar men are fittingly
ominous at first
insinuating the pecking order of the
monsters wham ac dc
and cars the two fights that take place
concerning caesar and jojo versus the
pillar men are both great at
highlighting and serving the jojo
character and what sets him apart from
pretty much any other
qualified person in this instance it's
not his hammond it's his grit and
intelligence the same attributes that
gave him the edge in every fight that
he's taken part in
the fact that he's besting people
utilizing his unique characteristics
make us feel all the more invested and
connected to what's transpiring on
screen we understand and recognize that
this is the element of his personality
that works for him in fights
and if this particular element to his
character is overcome we know that he
doesn't really have much else up his
[Music]
sleeve
not just a hat rack my friend one
drawback to this encounter is that it
very clearly at least for me is there to
serve as exposition for the pillar man
now i praised the previous fight for
doing it right so what did this one do
wrong
normally this would be fine considering
it also acts as a springboard for the
story to launch into a jojo training act
but because the pyramid consistently
remind us of what their motivations are
through dialogue to get the ruby to
conquer the day etc
this being reiterated over and over
stood out to me at times as clunky
storytelling
it's only a small thing but it's
something i thought was worth mentioning
moving on i actually really like the
fact that jojo had to bluff his way out
of the fight with the pillarmen this is
a callback to the gambling contest with
caesar he shared with him in the scene
before he wanted to prove to caesar that
he was the better of the two
and right as the fight ends despite his
trachea and heart being tied up in
poisonous rings
he managed to show caesar his chops and
impressed him one other clear advantage
to this particular scene is that it
establishes a time limit of 30 days to
defeat the pillar men
before the poison's rings kill him and
they achieve their goal the training
line
caesar introduces jojo to this character
her name is lisa lisa and lisa lisa will
train jojo by placing a mask on him to
control his breathing
no one cared who i was till i put on the
mask
he has demonstrated in the past that he
is quick to action starts strong and
then gets tired this will help him
control his breathing everything that's
happened before this was great and i
thoroughly enjoyed it but
i love training axe and now that there's
a time limit a sensei to teach him how
to get stronger and a clear goal
things started to become all the more
focused and i really enjoyed that
element of it
training part one the hellcline pillow
the hellclem pillar is a
massive hole coated in oil and they need
to claim out of this thing
using only their hammock and it's simple
it needs to understand tasks like this
that i knew would again highlight the
resourcefulness and tenacity of joseph's
character
and by the way i'm aware i'm bringing up
his character consistency
a lot but really this is what the story
is constantly in service of largely with
a lot of its scenes
they are designed to have joey joestar
bounce off the surrounding cast or
environment in an effort to reinforce
himself
and to bring forth conflict in this
particular challenge caesar is clearly
more advanced but once again jojo's best
performance comes when he's thinking
abstractly however lisa lisa puts a stop
to that behavior
jojo is now in a predicament where he
can't think his way out of this
he simply must think linearly and
overcome this hurdle
the way it was designed to be overcome i
love this scene not just because of the
philosophy that it employs but also
because jojo manages to overcome this
particular trial by adhering to the
rules while also applying
abstract thought to overcome the
problems that the challenge presents
thereafter
leading him to completing this trial in
a manner no one has performed before
with the help of caesar too caesar's a
good boy okay so it's around this time i
start to feel like there are small
problems with the story so don't hate me
okay oh excuse me
lisa lisa is a cool character but don't
like that she wants to keep the super
ios stone safe without understanding why
it's important to keep it safe
she just says it's because legend says
there are clearly understood advantages
to destroying it here and now with no
known reason to keep it in her
possession it is the one thing that
allows the pillarment to complete their
plan and i really for the life of me
don't understand why it's important to
keep it around besides to prolong the
story okay that's one bad thing okay now
time to move on to something good jojo
moves to complete his last trial and
defeat loggins his trainer
but instead finds him dead and the
pillarmen ac dc
there it is a fantastic fight that
honestly
would feel so strange in any other
context but it works so well as a jojo
fight and
when i say making your audience
anticipate a training sequence only to
be met with a surprise boss battle
against one of the strongest characters
in the arc was a brilliant move by araki
the fight itself takes place on a
spike-filled arena and employs some
clever tactics on behalf of joey joestar
that honestly boarded on the line of
lunacy and absurdity more than a few
times
i mean he uses a string from his hat but
also
ties other string in a specific way as a
decoy
all in a few split seconds that we don't
see but we'll see afterwards i'm
honestly not sure if i like it that much
from a narrative point of view but i'll
chalk it down as a silly fight that was
really fun because
it was it was a really fun fight in this
battle joseph finally overcomes ac dc
and wipes him out
jojo's training is complete
oh my god retrieve the package
okay so i really really didn't like this
specific section
that follows after jojo's fight with ac
dc all right so
ac dc is spoilers still alive kinda and
possesses lisa lisa's assistant susie q
who then takes the redstone
and ships it to switzerland and only
after defeating ac dc inside suzy q
does lisa lisa perform hammond hypnosis
and reveals that it was in fact sent to
switzerland
uh okay now maybe i'm missing something
here but
that feels insufferably contrived at no
point was i made aware that
hammond hypnosis could ever be a thing
or maybe i just forgot
it's totally possible but this when i
was reading it hit me as
an action that exists for the sole
purpose of moving the plot forward and
getting the gang to switzerland
which you know it's a fine motivation
for a scene but it shouldn't be the only
thing that informs it if you want to do
something like hammond hypnosis
foreshadow it okay so the evil german
bad guys arrive at the train to grab the
package before jojo and ko
but for some reason the gang don't take
it by force
despite not having any reason not to
just take it from the germans
who they have no reason to suspect are
anything other than human at this point
they instead resign themselves to the
idea that it's fine for the stone to be
in the hands of anyone else other than
the pillar men
and immediately in the next scene it's
revealed that strawheim the tenacious
german soldier from the start is back
with cyborg enhancements and begins to
school on cars once he starts attacking
he's got a gatling gun in his sternum
it's here i realized that jojo and code
didn't attack the soldiers because of
whatever reason they said but it's more
so because they wanted to have this
scene where strawheim unveils his
abilities in front of cars and not in
front of jojo kars takes out strohan but
the stone goes flying over a cliff
jojo and cars dive after it but thanks
to some quick thinking on behalf of jojo
and some clutch teamwork on behalf of
caesar the two survive while also taking
the stone home
thankfully on top of now having the
stone and creating distance between
themselves and the pillar men
they now not only have the stone they
now also know
where the stone was going and thus the
hideout in switzerland
of wham and cars comes into focus
death death is a ubiquitous consequence
in storytelling these days and sometimes
it's used to great effect
with that said in part one of jojo i
didn't feel particularly attached to any
one character
save for perhaps jonathan at the very
end and
even then it certainly wasn't enough to
invoke an emotional response from me in
any sort of meaningful way
i cared about jonathan's dog but not
enough to dwell in it for long
i couldn't care less about any of the
mansion fights casualties particularly
jonathan's father
and despite zeppelin being handled with
far greater care than any other
supporting character up until this point
when he did eventually die i still
didn't feel too much for him however i
cannot say that battle tendencies
suffered that same fate
while i still didn't feel a particular
connection to the vast majority of the
side characters there was one that stood
head and shoulders above
all the others that came before him both
in this part and the prior
caesar zeppely unlike his grandfather
whom we saw share the screen and pages
with jonathan all those years ago
happily
caesar and jonathan's relationship has
shown one thing that most other
relationships in this series have failed
to recognize so far
change and development over time coming
into contact with joseph at around the
same point in the story as williams
eppley did with jonathan
in and around the halfway point we see
upon first meeting caesar and joseph
being two
brash and confident personalities who
would clash on many occasions
and while i found their dynamic to be
massively entertaining it also provided
a launching off point for the
relationship act to flourish over the
course of many fights
trials and tribulations jojo and caesar
always despite their disagreements had
each other's backs with caesar in
particular there to catch jojo whenever
he would fall
then this happens
[Music]
caesar
alone the young caesar's eppley fell to
the power of wham in
a hard-fought battle the framing and
paneling throughout this story has been
of a high standard but this section here
in particular
it's clear there's a lot of attention
given to it the details of when caesar
foss
is slain and ultimately discovered by
lisa lisa and joseph thereafter
are all fittingly evocative of the
emotion they wish to capture and
somewhat ironically
jojo has spent the duration of this arc
trying to better himself as a fighter to
not blindly charge into battle on some
emotional whim
and while he does achieve that
throughout the duration of this tale
caesar unfortunately makes that very
same mistake
and pays for it it's a terrific scene
and it's probably for me the most
memorable moment in
all of the story save for perhaps one
moment that follows soon after
the final battle proceeding into the
final volume of this part was honestly a
thrilling experience the framing of the
coming scenes both from a paneling
perspective and a narrative one had me
in a knot of nerves
building two and clearly demonstrating
lisa lisa as a master of hammond not
only created anticipation for her
performance later but it also presented
the writer an opportunity to reveal that
through lisa lisa's mastery of hammond
the entire ceiling of the building they
entered is covered in vampires to defeat
this more than any other is lisa lisa's
seen to steal she negotiates the terms
of the fight
demonstrates her abilities and overall
takes the reins on this occasion
she will fight cars and jojo will fight
wham oh
also lisa lisa's got like a complicated
pass that's linked closely with joseph's
family
she's 50 and oh look vampire horses
the joseph joser versus wham battle is
fun as
all hell but really the moment that
stood out to me the most was when joseph
fastens caesar's hachimaki
onto his head it's short but it's a
quiet moment signifying that caesar will
be fighting with him made all the more
clear as the last thing
caesar did before passing on was leave
his remaining life force
to jojo much like his grandpa did all
those years ago for jonathan and if i'm
being honest
this fight right here is peak joseph
joestar he's cunning he's confident and
he looks
damn good look at the scarf in hachimaki
and this outing he has against wham
demonstrates
just that implementing everything that
made all the prior fights with him so
compelling to begin with it's got some
truly stunning visuals more twists and
turns than any other fight presented to
us thus far and really
made joseph feel like some sort of crazy
genius this is the most involved fight
in the entire arc up until this point
and one that makes full use of all of
wham's established abilities with an
ending that ties back to its beginning
at the beginning of this battle
jojo asks quietly to himself that caesar
be with him in this outing and jojo in
this final fight
quite literally could not have won if
not for what caesar physically and
emotionally
left behind igniting the fire that
consumes the arena caesar's hachimaki
envelops wham acting as the emotional
high point and my personal favorite part
of this spectacular fight encapsulating
everything i love about jojo
its style humor creativity and heart
[Music]
lisa lisa lost and now cars is about to
take over the world and there are
vampires
everywhere
oh okay didn't expect that at all don't
even know how they managed to find them
seeing as everyone who knew where they
were
has either died or is knocked out and i
guess araki didn't know either because
he moves on from the scene almost
immediately seriously uh strohm shows up
and
jojo's battle with cars begins like two
pages later but who cares
vampire squirrel to be perfectly frank
while i thought the scope of this fight
was fittingly larger than all of the
others
and it employed elements seldom seen in
the series like vampire animals coming
out of everywhere
i don't think i enjoyed this fight with
cars nearly as much as i did the fight
with wham
for one simple reason emotional
significance
the bond i recognized between caesar and
jojo was far greater and for me
acted as the emotional climax of this
story this just felt like a more
extravagant second act
to me though i did still really like it
despite it having a rather contrived
ending in the volcano suddenly going off
thus
winning jojo the bout despite this i do
recognize the subversion in the only
fight jojo wins without his one step
ahead type thinking
is the final boss fight of the arc and
he loses his arm too so
that's nuts so in a way i can see the
method behind this madness however it
just didn't gel as well as the prior
fight with wham did for me really but
that is a small nitpick in a story that
honestly fills me with so much joy and
excitement from beginning to end
punctuated beautifully by jojo's sudden
arrival at his own funeral
at the very end there's a fantastic
sense of friendship and community in
this and it really felt 100 distinct
from jonathan's story from the act prior
in my opinion this was a massive
improvement in the right direction and i
can't wait to finally cover some
material next week that i've never been
exposed to before
because truth be told stardust crusaders
is a total
[Music]